the word inequality by its very nature
at least sounds
sounds a little bit unfair obviously
everyone's not getting the same thing
they're not getting the same income or
they don't have the same wealth but a
question needs to be asked is is this
necessarily a bad thing and even if it
is a bad thing are the ways of fixing it
or trying to address it could they make
matters worse in some way way especially
for the people that you're trying to
help and once again my goal here is to
not tell you one way or the other but to
at least give you frameworks for
thinking about this
so let's just think about
a world where we have kind of a fixed
pie economy and their increasing
inequality is clearly not doing good for
for the people who have less resources
so let's imagine a fixed pie economy so
let's say this
this
this rectangle right over here
represents the total
national income in a given period
so year
one this is the total national income
total
national
income
and let's say that in year one the top
of earners the top 10 percent of earners
make a third
of the national income
so they make a third of the national
income this is the top 10 percent now
let me be very clear this area right
over here is not 10
of the whole rectangle this is 35
percent or actually this is
i said this is a third so this is going
to be 33 this is one-third of the entire
rectangle but it's the income from the
top 10
income from
the top
now that would mean that the other 90
other 90
is essentially splitting the remaining
the remaining two-thirds of national
income between them
so if you go if you take this reality
and if the total pi
so let's so let's do a static pi right
over here so pi stays the same
so pi
and when i say pi i'm talking about the
square thing here i guess it doesn't
look too too much like a pi so maybe i
don't call it a pi so national income
national income static so it's not
changing right over here so then you
have let me try to draw a rectangle of
the same size
of the same size
and if you have increasing inequality in
this situation
then you might have the top 10 percent
of earners by let's just say this is
year 10
year
10 right over here maybe instead of
having one third of the national income
maybe they have 50 of the national
income and i'm just picking round
numbers for simplicity so this right
over here is one half of national income
now from the top 10
from
the top
from the top 10 percent so clearly if
this happens the other 90 percent are
now splitting only one half of the
national income
so this is the other
other
90 right over here so here it's
essentially a zero zero-sum game if you
had a static economy if it was not
growing at all then of course rising
inequality would mean that these people
right over the other 90
are going to have
lower per capita i guess you could say
income lower per capita gdp they're
going to have a lower standard of living
so they're not doing good in this
situation
but let's think of the other way of
where you do have economic growth and
economic growth that's enough so even if
you have some inequality the growth more
than offsets that so that the the other
90 is still better off so let's see if
we can visualize that
so
so economic growth
economic
growth and let's say your pie has grown
dramatically over 10 years and i'm just
maybe i'm exaggerating a little bit for
the sake of for the sake of discussion
so let me draw it like this
so i'll try to draw the same height
but now
our whole economy let's say our whole
economy has
has doubled
our whole economy has doubled here
and now in this situation let's say you
still have this wealth inequality
growing so the top 10 percent in year
one having one third of national income
let's say that it still grows to one
half of national income in year 10.
so one half of national income
so i can draw that a little bit neater
so
half of national income right over there
half of national income so
one half of national income so this is
still a situation where you've had
inequality increase
but
the half of national income that's going
to have to be split between the other
ninety percent has still grown fairly
dramatically if we assume that i've
drawn it pretty close to proportional so
let me just copy and paste this
so
copy and paste so this is how much was
being split amongst the other 90
in year one and notice
it's much smaller than how much is being
split by the other 90 and actually let
me put it right over here then the other
in year ten and if we assume that the
population hasn't grown by this amount
it's grown by something smaller than
this or maybe the population has been
relatively stable then your per capita
your per capita gdp your per capita
income is actually going to improve
so this is a situation here where even
though inequality has increased because
the pie has gotten bigger these people
are better off
these people are better
and so that leads to really one of the
fundamental questions especially when
you're thinking about economic systems
is that you have this you have this
market system this capitalist system
this market economy
the market economy and
at least in the recent history it's
shown us that hey this is this leads to
growth wealth creation so pie so
economic growth
economic
growth
but it also leads to inequality
it also leads to inequality inequality
is an inevitable byproduct
in equality
now the question you have you might have
to ask is well look is this necessarily
bad if this economic growth is enough
everyone is better off it doesn't matter
if some people are even more better off
than other people but everyone is better
off and it's important to think about if
you try to
just focus on inequality just focus
inequality are you also going to stop
this from happening another way of
thinking about it if you're one of the
people in this in this situation right
over here that you're the other 90
percent would you rather stay in this
world
where you're in a static pie and
inequality is not increasing or would
you rather go to this world right over
here
now once again the point of my video
isn't to say that this world is
necessarily going to happen there could
be a world where your total economic
growth was less than this and the pie
got bigger and these people are not as
well off but i the whole point of this
is just to highlight that inequality is
not necessarily always going to lead to
the people on i guess who are who are
getting less of the pie being worse off
if the pie grows fast enough and the
other thing to realize is well if you
sometimes you might in an attempt to
lessen inequality you might also stifle
economic growth and that might keep
everyone from being better off in this
scenario right over here so once again
it really depends on the context it
really depends on the situation and the
variables and the numbers you're looking
at but i just really want to emphasize
that there's no such thing as hey if
there's rising inequality it's going to
hurt always the other 90 it'll
definitely
benefit the people who are maybe in the
top 10 percent but also because that's a
byproduct of economic growth it might
make these people better off as well